why do you believe you're right about
trans people given the american
psychological association american
medical association american
psychoanalytics association i can go on
for about five more associations
um that are very prominent and govern
the um the existing like health uh
health government or
health industries within um like the
major western countries
and all of these associations have
multiple thousands of doctors
sociologists psychologists and with phds
in their respective fields backing the
idea that sex and gender are different
effectively gaining the medical
consensus for sex and gender being two
different concepts yet you have a
different opinion okay so sex and gender
are two different concepts but gender is
tied to biology so one of the big
problems that that you see in sort of
the the argument in favor of trans
rights is this notion that gender and
sex are completely separable they're not
completely separable if they are
completely separable then this means
that identifying people by their
subjective gender really has no
relevance as to whether they are a male
or female male and female are biological
terms so using terminology like male and
female to describe a self-describe
self-perception of of maleness or
femaleness is sort of a bizarre way of
arguing whether a thing is a man or a
woman so here's my question it's an
argument that my friend matt walsh likes
to make what is a woman define what a
woman is without reference to the word
woman please
um so this is actually a logical fallacy
called a red herring you're asking me a
question in different or um in order to
actually challenge my question without
no it isn't i'm saying that it really is
not i'm saying that biology i i'm
agreeing with you that the notion of
gender which is effeminateness or
masculinity can be different from
biology in the sense that biology is
just pure male or pure female but to
suggest that there is such a thing as an
effeminate male is not to suggest that
an effeminate male is now a woman
transgenderism makes the argument that
if you believe that you are a woman you
are there for a woman or if you believe
that you are a man you are therefore a
man i disagree with this there are
objective measures as to whether you're
a man or a woman there are objective
measures as to whether you are male or
female you're there there's certainly a
spectrum with regard to effeminateness
versus masculinity that's certainly true
that does not change the underlying
sexual dichotomy that is the basis for
all human reproduction
yeah you can
answer um right so this dichotomy is a
false dichotomy that isn't supported by
any of the medical associations that i
just named then let me explain medical
associations that i just named off would
actually support the uh idea that um
gender is biological this is something
that's completely untrue against every
single like medical consensus uh well
then i will just say that anyone who
suggests that gender has no reference
whatsoever to biology it's not connected
in any way to biology it's just full of
because if these things and the
reason i
and
and the re and the reason that i say
then you then you class it then you
actually just disagree with medical
consensus yes
yes i disagree with the false medical
consensus driven by politically driven
quote unquote doctors if any doctor
denies to me that there is a dichotomy
between male and female a sexual
dichotomy between male and female they
are ignorant and they are letting their
politics get in the way of their science
anybody who suggests to you that there
is such a thing for example as a
pregnant male is not a doctor they are
an activist
[Applause]
i'm very glad that none of these
opinions are actually accepted in
academia and haven't been for over 70
years synth is here on the bottom okay
so the notion that they haven't been
accepted for over 70 years is a bizarre
one considering they were accepted until
about five minutes ago and the basic
idea that male and female do not exist
runs counter to all mammalian biology
all of it not just human are we to
suggest that gender and and sex are
different in walruses how does this work
exactly like
are they different in bears any time you
have a any time you have all mammalian
reproduction is rooted in the idea that
there's a sexual dichotomy between male
and female to obscure that with all
sorts of semantic word games about how
you feel subjectively has no bearing on
whether male and female are categories
that exist and if you're trying to
define male and female with reference to
any subjective category that cannot be
identified by any metric whatsoever
other than how you feel today i
challenge whether that is scientific or
whether that is merely a self-perception
that is being guided by a political
agenda i'm sorry i could spend more time
on this but we have to guess the next
question i appreciate it